want to get back to this idea of freedom
because i think i
i may disagree with some of my
colleagues here a little bit
and i may sort of a little bit like five
percent defend aoc
but only to make a point about why aoc
is wrong about everything
aoc tweets out yesterday quote
sex work is work the federal government
has done almost
nothing to help people in months we must
pass stimulus checks
unemployment insurance small business
relief hospital funding etc
keep the focus of shame there not on
marginalizing people
surviving a pandemic without help this
is in response to
a political controversy that's been
stirring up in recent days over pornhub
pornhub's getting knocked pretty hard
right now which is great
over only fans which is this
democratized pornography where basically
this website
lures in any kind of young girl to
[Music]
become a pornographer herself and then
make
you know the promises you're gonna make
a lot of money and the 97 percent of
these people
are even higher don't really make much
money at all but they end up degrading
themselves and have these photos on the
internet forever and it's really not
good for their lives
now i'm skeptical of aoc's premise here
that uh you know the only way to survive
the pandemic
is to get involved in prostitution and
pornography i don't think that's true
i think there are other ways to make
money maybe maybe you can make more
money
per hour or something doing that but you
know the the costs of that to your
reputation
to your personal life to your psychology
you know it's not not great
i'm also sort of skeptical that we
shouldn't have shame
feel shame for these kind of lord sexual
behaviors
but instead we should feel shame because
politicians
you know haven't done their job i think
that
all people involved in sex work and
uh politics should probably feel some
shame you know those are the two oldest
professions right
prostitution's the oldest one and then
politics is just right after that
and as reagan pointed out they bear a
lot of similarities to one another
uh however the place i will agree with
aoc and disagree with some of my
conservative colleagues
is when she says sex work is work
obviously that's true
of course it's work it takes time
you get paid for it uh it does require
skill
i won't think too much about the skills
you know because that's not is a family
program but it does it does require i
suppose some kind of
skill even even a little business savvy
to attract a customer or you know it's
so it is work it's just bad work
it's not good work it's not good for
anybody
it's bad for the guys buying the
services it's bad for the women
providing the services it's bad for
society
it's bad you know there was there was a
while ago
who was it obama said i think it was
obama
some democratic politician said you know
if you don't work and study hard you're
gonna end up being a barista
being a barista is honest work that's an
honest
you're you know you're going out you're
providing a service i love my barista
you know
sex work and a certain type of politics
is not honest work
but it is work it's just you you don't
you don't want that for you know there
was a troll who tweeted out
obviously this was just to troll
conservatives into a frenzy
he said i'm my daughter is thriving on
pornhub
and only fans i'm the proud father of a
sex worker and
you know obviously that isn't true
nobody nobody
feels that way because there is
something intrinsically shameful
about looking at porn and about
performing in porn
and people at both sides have
psychological effects from that
you know there's one of the reasons that
pornhub has become such a big issue
is because you've got generations of
young boys who are getting hooked on
this
on this thing which is categorically
different and more categorically more
dangerous than a playboy under your
uncle's bed in the 70s you know or
something like that
this is very different it has very
damaging effects to people
this has been studied scientifically and
obviously that's true ethically as well
and it would seem to me that the way to
attack this problem is not to
stigmatize or marginalize people
who are in it and it's it's not to uh
permit it and entirely and just say well
you've got to raise your kids better but
the government has no role
politics is no role no it's obviously
bad it's really bad
i mean it's really shameful of aoc to
encourage young girls to get involved in
prostitution which is what she's doing
that's that's a shameful thing and that
that could ruin lives
we should not do that we should
discourage girls from getting involved
in pornography and prostitution
we should discourage men from looking at
and
engaging in those sorts of things we can
have prudence and recognize
there's always going to be some kind of
shady pictures on the internet
there's always going to be you know a
strip club or a brothel in the red light
district
and there's always going to be the
temptation of women to
get involved in that there's always
going to be the temptation of men to get
involved in that too
but we should try to minimize it you
know even
getting back to saint augustine who i
mentioned earlier with regard to
christmas
saint augustine defended
legal prostitution in the sense that
it's
it's prudent you know it's it's
impossible to eradicate entirely
there can be some externalities if you
do eradicate it entirely but you don't
want to encourage it you want you know i
understand that that's not satisfying to
either
the liberal left who says oh yeah
everybody should be a porn star
and to the extremely ideological rigid
right that says we've got to
eradicate lust from the heart of man i
don't think either of those are
particularly practical i think what we
should just do is
through prudence discourage all of this
activity and that involves some shame
for everybody involved that can be a
good thing shame is good that's your
that's your conscience
having a red blaring light saying danger
danger
don't don't do this and we should
encourage that faculty
that is a faculty of our reason that is
that is a sense that we should cultivate
so right now pornhub is getting hit with
this 40 million lawsuit
victims of a sex trafficking operation
are
are suing mind geek which is the parent
company
of pornhub because there was a sex
trafficking operation called girls do
porn very creatively titled and
basically this was a fraudulent porn
company and they lured the girls in
and said that actually these videos are
only going to be released
on dvd in foreign countries don't worry
none of your friends none of your family
is going to find it what do they do they
immediately upload
it to the internet and apparently to
pornhub in particular because i guess
the biggest
biggest website right so they upload all
of that these girls have their lives
ruined
they some of them threaten suicide some
of them attempt suicide so you know
their lives are completely shattered
which should be a warning sign to
anybody
who wants to get on onlyfans.com because
they think they can make a quick buck
obviously effects that you're not taking
into account here and these websites are
preying on girls who are not
taking these things into account so each
victim here
is asking for at least a million bucks
plus they're asking for the profits of
their videos and legal fees as well
that's good that's a good thing
i don't know if the right or the left
feel perfect about the
way that people are attacked they're
attacking pornhub because they've got
misogynistic content according to nick
kristof at the new york times and racist
content
and because they've got underage girls
yeah definitely go after him for that
and because they've got fraud
videos and they've got okay fine that's
sort of death by a thousand cuts and
you're not going to eradicate pornhub
entirely but you are going to cut it
down to size just the other day they
deleted something like half of the
videos on their platform how many
millions of videos do they have on their
platform they deleted half of them
that's good that's good that's a win
that's a good standard to have and you
know when people say you can't legislate
morality well that's obviously
ridiculous
all laws by definition legislate
morality but i think what people are
really saying is
you can't have a you know establish this
perfect moral society without any sin
yeah duh of course not of course people
are going to violate these sorts of
things but you can at least have the
standard
and that goes a long way what we've done
what what really what political
correctness has done for the past
50 years 100 years is to invert the
standards that we have in this country